how are you Pete then I can't hang
around for Heather Graham know about a
disappointment no you're just killing
time well just not a no Pete just you
could just hang up and listen
later on when we're done with this
conversation Texas is 2 & 2 right now
where do you put the Longhorns right now
what do you make of their first four
games of the Tom did a really
interesting ride they obviously got
annihilated give him 61 points to to
Maryland in that and that season opener
and and I really think from their rich
they learned some things I think they
got together defensively I was out in
Los Angeles the night they played USC
and despite losing and certainly in
Texas is not a home of moral victories
it did seem like they found a little bit
of an identity that night the defense
played with an edge that it hadn't had
and it seemed like the the Mojo that Tom
Herman and Todd Orlando the defensive
coordinator had at Houston made its way
up to Austin that night and so how much
can you read into a Thursday road win at
Iowa State I don't know but 17-7
promising our state's the program on the
upswing so right now this case date game
is a huge test because Bilson teams are
just sort of like relentless winning
please you know despite the talent
levels that have fluctuated over the
years they don't make mistakes they are
precise and concise and surgical so I
think I think it's a fascinating test
for the Longhorns at this very early
stage of Tom Herman's tenure there to go
up against it's my Kansas State and you
know obviously first month of a season
in college football what appears to be
an impressive win in the first month
when we matriculate our way through the
schedule no longer looks as such and
obviously Texas and Notre Dame from week
one last year just screams that what do
you make of USC
I know Texas again the defense looked
really stout in that game that was such
an entertaining game but then USC goes
up to Washington State and and and
couldn't come out with the win what do
you make of us see is we're sitting here
in October Pete so USC is one of those
teams that I do think gets a little bit
chronically over ranked and
over-romanticized I remember sent in
clay Helton office early this season he
said to be you know Stanford won 10
games last year and they were not a
whole lot of magazine covers I'm
paraphrasing but or something
theft and the fact that USC has a golden
boy quarterback or who is perceived to
be a golden quarterback before the
season I just think people fell in love
with the narrative a little bit I think
they're very good rich and losing to
this Washington State team on the road
is not a I don't think a mortal sin I
mean this is this is leaches best team
they're by far the old pirate knows what
he's doing
you know and Alex grinch the defensive
coordinator of Washington State has an
actual college defense there it's not a
good for Washington State defense it's
like actually good competent collegiate
defense so I wasn't stunned that they
lost their look good teams are gonna be
challenged and their league on the road
you know the question is in the pac-12
can USC rebound to the point where if
they end up matched up with Washington
that then the year will be good enough
to beat him I mean most of this USC hype
was derived from a the Rose Bowl in be
going to Seattle last year and pushing
around the Huskies on the road and you
know we did we haven't seen that type of
performance yet from USC this season but
they are talented and it's still early
DirecTV 4k college football report with
Pete famil from Yahoo Sports here and
you mentioned how good teams are gonna
get threatened in conference on the road
could that be Alabama at Texas A&M this
weekend what do you think it could you
know we'll learn a lot about Texas A&M
you know if they didn't just completely
melt down and one of the the worst sort
of coating and play-calling performances
I've ever seen out at the Rose Bowl and
week one this game would have a lot more
juice I think what I learned from
watching am in that game is that they
are pretty talented they they you know
they they really ran the ball well in
that game and had a pretty stout
defensive front that harassed Josh Rosen
for for three quarters but I mean that
that that one quarter in the Rose Bowl
my probably one quarter in two minutes I
guess really changed the whole the whole
narrative I I think that now I think
Alabama's gonna roll I was going to make
a case for it but just there's so much
empirical evidence that's that I'll be
able to given us this season and seasons
past it's just hard
it's hard to question they're they're
sort of robotic dominant the empirical
evidence is all on Clemson side if you
want to talk about anything right now I
mean first team in 37 years to beat five
top 15 teams in their first five games
first team in the history of the 81
years of the poll to have three such
wins over top 15 teams in before we're
even in October
why aren't they number one right now
Pete I think that probably has more to
do with history than current events you
cannot overstate what clemson has
accomplished this year and I I think I
don't know it goes back to sort of
fundamentally how you how you how you
rank teams you rankings on where you
think they'll be at the end of the year
do you rank them what they've
accomplished a month in if you rank
alabama number one to serve the season
they haven't given you a whole lot of
reason to move them down you know so I
think that's again I think it's too
early to say those two were so much
dominant they're on a collision course
college football is just filled with
like wacky wacky things I mean Clemson
she lost NC State last year and probably
never made the college to a playoff like
it was it was a Miss chip shot field
goal so a college football is not a
world of absolutes it's just sort of
inherent to the nature of it which which
makes it great but I I think Alabama has
sort of earned has earned the sort of
right to to be number one preseason to
say number one until they do something
to lose that spot okay a couple more
minutes with Pete famil of Yahoo Sports
in the DirecTV 4k college football
report Michigan against Michigan State
this weekend Joe no corns gonna be the
quarterback for quite some time and and
that this is the meat of the schedule
right here
they got Michigan State at home Penn
State in a couple weeks in Penn State
and you know you know Penn State wants
to win that game in the worst way as
they got whipped up in Ann Arbor last
year and then became a completely
different program after that Pete what
do you think about Michigan's chances
here are you asking for you richer for
your audience Pete I am asking for the
audience I always ask for the audience
even though what is the name of the show
here Mike Dell to foe what is it I just
drop it one more time what for Pete this
is the Rich Eisen show
think Pete got it well rich and your
audience this is a little bit of an
enigma you know I I look there's a
reason why Johnno corn hasn't been the
starter at Michigan you know there I
mean I remember him from his from his
rise at Houston I believe he would be
the league Player of the Year his a
freshman of the year his first year
there and he's been around long enough
for I don't even remember if that league
was the piece for the American Athletic
Conference because the world's changed a
lot in John Oh corns five years with us
on the college football world I'm pretty
sure was the a Snead now that I think
about it but he's obviously talented guy
just you know there look Jim Harbaugh
knows so much more about quarterback
play than you and I and all of your
audience combined probably so you've got
to think there's you know it's not like
they just discovered this guy and you
know the back of chemistry class so I'll
be curious with you know what you know
what this time to prepare and the
pressure on how John will form responds
mentally to the challenge that is that
is ahead of him against against Michigan
State and this is quite frankly not a
very good Michigan State team there
aren't a lot of NFL prospects I feel
like the talent has the talent has been
drawn down and you know when I think
about Michigan this year rich the the
thing I think that impresses bedpost is
the job Don Brown is done as defensive
coordinator I'm gonna say they have they
have ten new starters I don't think
there's a better defensive coordinator
on college football the top around just
you think about what what they've done
in a short period of time to be just as
dominant essentially as they had been in
past or into it past editions it is it
is remarkable I wish I knew enough about
football to explain why Don Brown is as
good at his job as he is in terms of
nuances and Exynos but I don't I just
know that you keep looking up at the top
ten every year and you see Boston
College Michigan wherever he happens to
be right in that right in that
neighborhood he's a he's a ninja all
right Pete thanks very much appreciate
it I wish I heard what you said the last
two minutes because Heather Graham
walked on the set during your last
thanks for coming on the show I
appreciate it thank prefigurative that's
directivity 4k college football report
from Pete saml of yahweh's for
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on radio stations across the
country and audience if you liked that
video be sure to download our app and
I'll be sure to help the NFL figure out
what it catches